[Music]
foreign
so we've been talking a lot about how to
solve systems of differential equations
Matrix Systems of first order
differential equations x dot equals ax
where a is a matrix and X is a vector of
states and I essentially you know have X
as an n-dimensional Vector with n
components a is an N by n Matrix and
this would represent n
first order ordinary differential
equations A first order differential
equation for X1 for X2 for X3 and so on
and so forth down to xn
and we've looked at looked at simple
cases where a has distinct eigenvalues
eigenvalues that are not repeated and so
today I'm going to talk about what
happens when you have repeated
eigenvalues so specifically I'm actually
going to look at two cases two different
a matrices that have repeated
eigenvalues
the first one I'm going to look at is
the case a equals 1 0 0 1 which is
almost trivially easy because it's
already diagonal but again this does
have two distinct sorry two repeated
eigenvalues Lambda equals one and Lambda
equals one
so this is going to be one case we're
going to look at and the other case
we're going to look at
is this similar case a equals 1 1 0 1.
so this also has the same repeated
eigenvalues Lambda equals one and Lambda
equals one but we're going to show that
these have very very different Dynamics
these have very different uh Dynamics
and different solutions for these two
cases even though they both have
repeated eigenvalues Lambda equals one
twice
okay um and in the other cases I've
shown you in the past there is
essentially this idea that you can
diagonalize a with eigenvalues and
eigenvectors diagonalize diagonalize
a with
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
eigenvectors
and you know eigenvalues eigenvectors
and eigenvalues and specifically my
eigenvectors come in a matrix T and my
eigenvalues come in a diagonal matrix D
and if I have a
these eigenvectors and eigenvalues then
I can take t
inverse a t and that's going to equal
this diagonal matrix and what we've been
assuming up until now is that this
diagonal matrix essentially consists of
Lambda 1 maybe I'll write Lambda 2 dot
dot dot Lambda n
and zeros everywhere else I've been kind
of implicitly assuming that all of these
lambdas are distinct and different
eigenvalues not like this case where I
have repeated eigenvalues where I have
two eigenvalues that are Lambda equals
one I've been kind of implicitly
assuming that I have distinct
eigenvalues here and so this is a little
bit of a special case I'll tell you
about and then we'll revisit this kind
of General diagonalization here
and so specific
Ally there are
some math theorems I don't usually give
you like theorems and proofs and like
real kind of rigorous math that give you
just the feeling of the math but there's
some important properties of when you
can diagonalize a system like this when
the eigenvectors T form a complete basis
for this n dimensional Vector space that
my Vector X lives in so
you know X
lives in an N dimensional Vector space
this means it's it's n an n-tupole of
real numbers it's a vector okay and this
Matrix
key of eigenvectors all of those
eigenvectors all of those directions
will span a basis for this argument this
n-dimensional Vector space
if so if
if all eigen eigenvalues if all the
eigenvalues
Lambda
of a
are real and distinct
real and distinct
meaning they're not equal to each other
then essentially my eigenvectors T the
eigenvectors eigenvectors
t
an this n dimensional Vector space they
span RN and what that means is this is a
real n-dimensional Vector space what
that means is that any Vector you could
name any X in this space that you could
possibly name is going to be a linear
combination of The Columns of t or the
eigenvectors of my a matrix and that's a
really useful property that means that
kind of any initial condition I have any
initial State any X Vector in this space
can be written as a linear combination
of columns of my eigenvectors The
Columns of the Matrix T which are
eigenvectors of a so they form a
complete basis that spans RN if the
eigenvalues of Lambda
are real and distinct so I'll underscore
real and distinct
if they are not
distinct
might be some issues with this
diagonalization procedure I won't be
able to write it as a purely diagonal
system there might be a couple of
off-diagonal entries like this guy here
it's impossible to perfectly diagonalize
this Matrix I'm always going to have
this off diagonal entry here in my D
Matrix no matter what I do there's no
coordinate transformation that will get
rid of this little upper one that's not
diagonal and so there's exceptions to
this idea that you can diagonalize your
Matrix and in particular if I have
repeated eigenvalues sometimes I won't
be able to get perfectly diagonal
matrices
um but you think you get things that are
close to diagonal and I'll show you that
uh kind of in this lecture
in a little bit but I kind of want to
zoom into these two matrices and look at
what is different just by changing this
little number here
okay
so clearly
um you know Lambda
one equals 1 and Lambda 2 equals one are
both eigenvalues so this is what we call
a repeated a repeated
eigenvalue eval e value
for any diagonal matrix or any Matrix
that has a lower triangle of zeros or an
upper triangle of zeros you can verify
I'll just write this down
if I have a big a matrix and I've got
you know A1 A2 dot dot dot dot a n and
I've got some stuff up here
um you know a one two a one three dot
dot dot a two three dot dot dot so these
are non-zero
but I have zeros below the diagonal
below the diagonal then the eigenvalues
of this Matrix are the diagonal entries
these are you know Lambda 1 equals A1
Lambda 2 equals A2 and so on and so
forth and this is really
this Matrix minus
Lambda times the identity Lambda Lambda
dot dot dot Lambda
and then you take its determinant and
set it equal to zero and because of the
structure of this Matrix the determinant
is going to be the product just of the
diagonal entries because it has this
lower triangle of zeros and so the
product of that determinant is just
going to be A1 minus Lambda times A2
minus Lambda times A3 minus Lambda times
dot dot dot and so the lambdas that
satisfy that characteristic equation
that determinant equals zero are exactly
Lambda equals A1 Lambda equals A2 and so
on and so forth so when I say I can just
read off these eigenvalues or the
eigenvalues are one and one I'm using
this property here so you could kind of
pause this video if you want and really
convince yourself that for this kind of
Matrix the eigenvalues are going to be
on the diagonal same thing if I if I
transpose this so I have numbers on the
bottom and zeros on the upper triangle
same exact thing applies okay I'm going
to erase this and then we're going to
revisit this and um so the next thing
I'm going to do is compute the
eigenvectors but the eigenvectors of
this Matrix are kind of trivial because
we know that one of the eigenvectors
uh C1 is going to equal the one zero
Direction and another eigenvector C2 is
going to equal the 0 1 Direction because
to some extent this thing is already
diagonalized so the the normal kind of X
and Y coordinates X and Y unit vectors
are already going to diagonalize the
system because it's already diagonal I
don't have to do any change of
coordinates so my T Matrix if you like
is going to be the identity because it's
already diagonal my system's already
diagonal so I only multiply it by the
identity to diagonalize it good
um
and the way you think about this
um you could solve for these if you
liked you could literally solve for
these by taking
um a minus Lambda identity
a minus Lambda to the identity
and then trying to find what x vectors
would map to zero for that for that
Lambda equals one and this is kind of
trivial because a minus Lambda times the
identity is a matrix zero zero zero zero
so literally any X is going to map to
zero for that Lambda equals one repeated
eigenvalue and so what we say
Matrix has
uh rank
0 it has zero Span in RN it has zero
um zero rank there are no vectors in
this matrix it's just a zero Matrix and
um
so it has a two dimensional null space
basically because this thing um any
Vector will map to zero that means this
has a two dimensional null space spanned
by this vector and this Vector the two
eigenvectors of my system okay so this
was kind of a trivial case we didn't
have to go through all of this math
because you can just read off that the
eigenvalues are one and that it's
already diagonal so my eigenvector
Matrix is the identity but let's look at
this uh this case here this kind of more
interesting case where I have this weird
little
upper one here and maybe I'll do this in
green
so similarly I can write down that
Lambda 1 equals 1 and Lambda 2 equals
one are my repeated eigenvalues
because I can read it off because it's a
diagonal matrix with lower triangle of
zero
and now I'm going to look at the same a
minus Lambda I Matrix so a minus Lambda
I and I'm still going to look for X that
mapped to 0 a minus Lambda I
is
this thing minus the identity is going
to equal
0 1 0 0.
this thing does not have rank zero it
has rank one there's one vector that has
a direction and so this spans a
direction
um and so what we're going to find
essentially
because this is rank
one it only has
one eigenvector
or One X that maps to zero and so we can
find out what that is we can literally
take zero one zero zero and we can
multiply this by you know x one and X2
and that's we're hoping gonna equal zero
so let's just do that that equals you
know x two
zero and we want this to equal zero
that's what we're looking for our
vectors X that map to zero and so any
Vector X that has a zero in the X2
component will map to zero so c 1 equals
you know one zero
that Vector maps to zero and so this is
an eigenvector corresponding to Lambda
equals one good
but I'm not going to be able to find
another eigenvector I'm not going to be
able to find another direction that maps
to zero in this Subspace I'm not going
to find any direction that has x
x 2 not equal to zero
and X so the only other direction here
that's orthogonal is
0 1 and that's certainly not an
eigenvector of this because 0 1 does not
map to zero so this is the only
eigenvector for this a minus Lambda I
and so what do we do we don't have
enough eigenvectors we don't have a
complete basis to diagonalize our system
to transform the system into into a
diagonal form it's not going to work
and so instead what you what you in this
case where you don't have a complete
basis and you can't diagonalize your
system this doesn't hold because they
don't have distinct eigenvalues
then
what you do is next you look for
um
the X's that are in the null space of a
minus Lambda I
squared okay A minus Lambda I squared
and so a minus Lambda I squared
um
is
this the Subspace of this that maps to
zero so now we're looking for X's that
map this to e to zero and that's going
to give me a second generalized
eigenvector so I should call this C
sorry let's call this C
um let's call it C2 in fact
C2 so this is a second
and we call it generalized a generalized
eigenvector
and so that is essentially
um
kind of an important thing you do when
you have repeated eigenvalues is first
thing you do is you look at a minus
Lambda I and if the Subspace if the null
space of this Matrix meaning the number
of orthogonal x's that map to zero if
the null space of this Matrix I'm going
to say that again meaning the number of
orthogonal or X's that map to zero if
that null space has the same Dimension
as the the number of times this
eigenvalue is repeated then we don't
have to do anything we just take the two
eigenvectors from that two-dimensional
null space and those two eigenvectors
will span T and we can still diagonalize
our system as in this case where it's
clearly already diagonal so that's
possible
but if a minus Lambda I has a null space
that is smaller than the number of
repeated eigenvalues so this null space
is one dimensional not two-dimensional
so this null space is smaller than the
number of repeated eigenvalues
eigenvalues then I I'm not going to have
enough eigenvectors I won't be able to
perfectly diagonalize my system and I'm
going to have to start looking at
generalized eigenvectors down here okay
generalized eigenvectors that are going
to map uh map to zero
and uh the generalized eigenvector here
is going to be
I mean in this case this is kind of
trivial because a minus Lambda I
squared If I multiply this by itself
again it just becomes the zero Matrix so
this literally becomes you know zero
zero zero zero
and so that again now has a
two-dimensional null space and so there
is a direction perpendicular to C1
another direction that I will need to
span RN and so I can just pick that to
be 0 1 if I like or I can pick it to be
one one if I like there's it's a
two-dimensional null space down here
so uh good now
I'll give you some other examples of um
I'm just going to choose the one that's
perpendicular to my C1 okay this is
going to be uh
this is
C2 equals this
um
good but in this case
I'm never going to be able to perfectly
diagonalize this Matrix there is no T
that is going to perfectly diagonalize
this Matrix to have zeros everywhere
else except on the diagonal I'm never
going to be able to get rid of this
upper one here okay and in the previous
lecture I showed you that the solution
of this e to the Matrix a t is equal to
you know e to the t e to the T on the
diagonal like we expect zero and then a
t e to the T on this upper diagonal and
this is a consequence of the fact that I
can't remove that one there so I get
these secular terms that give me
um you know kind of this transient rise
before Decay type behavior in this case
it's unstable so it's just going to be
unstable but if this was minus T's if
this was minus one minus one my behavior
would look like this
okay good
um what else do I want to tell you so
this is more or less just showing you uh
what to do when you have repeated
eigenvalues in a problem
um you can either have the easy case
where the repeated eigenvalues
um
still have two distinct eigenvectors in
the Subspace of a minus Lambda I in the
null space of a minus Lambda I in which
case no problem I can still diagonalize
that case
so this is not an only if
definitely if my eigenvalues are real
and distinct then I definitely can
diagonalize my system
there will be some cases where my
eigenvalues are not distinct like this
one where I can still diagonalize it
it's still diagonal those cases are
where my null space of a minus Lambda I
has the same Dimension as the
multiplicity of my eigenvalues this has
a null space of Dimension two this has
multiplicity of the eigenvalues too so I
can still diagonalize the system
but then there is the other case where
the kind of rank of the the dimension of
my null space of a minus Lambda I is
only one dimensional but I have two
repeated eigenvalues I'm never going to
be able to perfectly diagonalize this
system I'm always going to have this
upper one this secular system here
that's an interesting outfall
so now I'm going to revisit this kind of
generic picture here if I had an
n-dimensional Matrix what would happen
What are some of the things I can have
in my you know once I applied these
these eigenvalue eigenvector coordinate
transformations
so
um
if I had
so what are the cases what are the just
generic behaviors I can get in a linear
system with n dimensions
um
so again I can get a perfectly diagonal
system if I have real distinct
eigenvalues
or if I have repeated eigenvalues that
are real but the multiplicity of those
eigenvalues is the same as the null
space dimension of a minus Lambda I then
I can still get this kind of diagonal
system here so that that's one case
another case that we've just seen is
that I might have so this is kind of the
case one kind of the easiest case
other things I could get is if I have
um we're always going to assume that a
is real valued so let's always assume
that uh
a has real values
because you know this comes from f
equals m a from a physical system X is
real a is real time is real Everything
Is Real at least to us humans but even
for real valued a I can still have
complex valued eigenvalues so that's
case two
uh so case two would be you know I can
still have complex eigenvalues
um but any let's say any complex
eigenvalues
any complex IGS Lambda must
come in complex conjugate pairs in
complex
conjugate
pairs
if a is real valued
and what that means is that you know if
I have Lambda equals a plus I B if I
have Lambda 1 equals a plus IB then I
need a Lambda 2 that's equal to a minus
IB that's the only way I can have a
complex eigenvalue of a real valued
Matrix
is if it has a complex conjugate pair so
we've seen this before
in our rotation Matrix from f equals m a
of the mass on a spring
we essentially had a matrix 0 1 minus
one zero and that real value Matrix did
have complex eigenvalues but they came
in pairs plus or minus I okay they came
in complex conjugate pairs
and in that case
um
you know let's say I shouldn't have done
a plus IB but I'm gonna I'm gonna stick
with it in that case you know T inverse
a t is is again it's not going to be
perfectly diagonal but it is going to
equal a block that looks nice this uh a
B minus B A I bet is what that is going
to be based on based on this so if I
have these complex conjugate pair
eigenvalues then I instead of
diagonalizing my my a matrix I can write
it in a form that has this structure
here and these are going to have those
eigenvalues that I wrote down
good and the eigen the exponential of
this the you know e to the a t is going
to equal something like you know cosine
um
this is going to equal uh
cosine BT
sine B T minus sine b t
cosine b t
all of that times do I have a little
teeny room over here times e to the A
T okay so it's going to have a real
value to e to the a t part and then this
rotation Matrix for this this imaginary
part plus or minus IB
okay so that's one thing you can have
um another thing you can have case three
is what I showed you here
case three
is where you have repeated eigenvalues
repeated
Lambda and
um a repeated Lambda
and
a not enough
null space and not
enough
null space directions in a minus Lambda
I and in that case you're going to get
you know T inverse a t equals Lambda
Lambda 1 0 that's going to be the the
kind of canonical thing that you're
going to get when you do this
eigenvector trans transformation and
these
called Jordan forms Jordan blocks this
is the Jordan form I'll write this down
Jordan was a mathematician
um Jordan not Air Jordans
uh Michael Jordan any of the Michael
Jordan's for that matter this is a
different Jordan
um and these are called Jordan canonical
forms this is the Jordan canonical form
for a pair of complex conjugate
eigenvalues this is the Jordan canonical
form for a set of repeated eigenvalues
uh where a minus Lambda I has less null
space than the number the multiplicity
of these eigenvalues this is the Jordan
canonical form for a set of distinct
real eigenvalues
and so if you have a bigger Matrix like
I have a 10 by 10 matrix it's going to
be built up it's going to be a diagonal
matrix built up out of these Jordan
blocks so if I have like eight distinct
real eigenvalues and a pair of complex
conjugate eigenvalues I'm going to get
something that looks like this for the
upper eight and then a little Jordan
block of my complex eigenvalues on the
on the last two entries and so you can
build build up this kind of block
diagonal matrix for T inverse a t in
general out of these Jordan block pieces
I'm going to erase this and I'm going to
say that again and I'm going to give you
a last example of this but for a 3X3
system and then I'll be done
okay um
and Matrix out of these Jordan blocks
maybe I'll just show you the kind of
three by three version of this
degenerate repeated eigenvalue case so
there's kind of two there's three
versions of this so I could have a
repeated eigenvalue Lambda Lambda Lambda
a Thrice repeated eigenvalue but I could
have
a Jordan block that looks like this that
is actually still honest to goodness
diagonal this would be the case if uh
rank if the rank of a minus Lambda I
equals
zero meaning the null space has is
three-dimensional the null space is
basically if this was like a big zero
Matrix and so its null space is is
three-dimensional then I can find three
clean unique eigenvectors to span the
space and I can actually diagonalize it
so we saw this already in the two
dimensional case okay
um another way that this can slice is I
could have a Jordan form that looks like
you know again repeated eigenvalues
Lambda Lambda Lambda zeros below and
then I get a single one up here and then
zeros everywhere else this is what's
going to happen if rank
of a minus Lambda I uh is one meaning
that this a minus Lambda I has a two
dimensional null space so I can find two
distinct eigenvectors but not a third
one then I'm still going to have the
secular term here
and then the last case
um
I'll go back to Orange the last case
would be uh if I have Lambda Lambda
lambda zero zero zero one one zero this
would be the case if rank of a minus
Lambda I
equals two meaning I only have a single
null space direction of a minus Lambda I
so I can only pull out one clean
eigenvector and then I need to find two
generalized eigenvectors so here I don't
need any generalized eigenvectors
because my null space is three
dimensional so I get three orthogonal
eigenvectors and I can diagonalize my
system
here if rank a minus Lambda I is 1 so my
null space is 2 dimensional then I can
find two good eigenvectors directly from
this and I only need one generalized
eigenvector I would need to look at
um I would need to look at a minus
Lambda I
squared for my generalized eigenvector
for a single generalized eigenvector
here but down here in the case that my
null space of this is only one
dimensional I need two more generalized
eigenvectors so I'm going to have to
look at a minus Lambda I
squared and presumably a minus Lambda I
cubed to get my two generalized
eigenvectors out of this so these are
the kinds of Jordan blocks that you can
get for a system with three repeated
eigenvalues so there are there are three
different types of systems that have
three that have three repeated
eigenvalues these are the three types
based on the rank of that a minus Lambda
I that null space where we search for
our eigenvectors to diagonalize our
system
um
good what else do I want to tell you
um
yeah the other thing is that for this
case here if I have this two-dimensional
null space then when I take my Matrix
solution
um you know e to the a t I'm going to
have terms that actually look like t
squared e to the Lambda T's I'm going to
get even worse secular terms so this guy
is going to give me terms like t e to
the Lambda t
but these guys are going to give me t
squared e to the Lambda T's and if I had
four repeated eigenvalues in the worst
case scenario where I had
um you know
um only one null space Direction I would
get T cubed e to the Lambda T secular
terms so there's all kinds of weird
stuff that you can have here
okay last thing I'm just going to show
you now if I have a generic n by n a
matrix okay so now I'm just going to
draw a little line here so now let's say
I have a an N by n a matrix
and let's say I have the following
eigenvalues I'm just going to write down
some eigenvalues and then I'm going to
draw you my Jordan form for that set of
eigenvalues so let's say that I have a
distinct
distinct real
Lambda 1 Lambda not two sorry Lambda 1
Lambda 2.
um
Lambda 3 dot dot dot to Lambda M okay
I've got M distinct eigenvalues and then
also let's say I have a complex
conjugate pair uh complex pair
let's call this Lambda plus or minus I
Omega okay that's a complex conjugate
pair and then let's say I have a
repeated pair repeated
pair and let's give it a different name
let's call it you know mu
uh times two I've got two mues but
a minus mu I
has a 2d null space
and then finally let's say I have a
repeated pair
repeated pair
instead of mu let's call it gamma times
two
but a minus gamma I
has a one-dimensional null space
by finding
fine nectares corresponding to all of
these eigenvalues I can transform my
system with t inverse a t into what is
called the Jordan canonical form so the
Jordan
canonical form canonical
form
that I would get by taking T inverse a t
it's not going to be strictly diagonal
but it's going to be as close to
diagonal as you can get for this system
and so that Jordan form it's going to
have a big block that is diagonal so
it's going to be this huge Matrix and
it's going to have you know Lambda 1
Lambda 2 dot dot dot to Lambda m
zeros here so this is a block Matrix
that's diagonal
and then I'm going to have another
Jordan block below it for this complex
pair so I'm going to have this little
block here which is I believe Lambda
Omega
minus Omega
Lambda this little Jordan block there
and then I'm going to add another Jordan
block for my repeated eigenvalues but
because a minus mu I has a
two-dimensional null space I can
diagonalize this one
so I'm going to have a little mu 0 0
mu block it'll actually be diagonal and
then my final block for these
eigenvalues the Jordan block for this
because a minus gamma I only has a
one-dimensional null space it's going to
look like this and that Jordan block is
going to be Gamma 1 0 gamma and
everywhere else is going to be zeros
so this is as close to diagonal as
possible but it's block diagonal in
terms of these Jordan blocks so my real
and distinct eigenvalues actually form a
diagonal Jordan block my complex
conjugate pair form a kind of skew
symmetric block my repeated pairs that
have a big null space are again
diagonalizable and my repeated pairs
that have a rank deficient null space
have this extra secular term here and so
every single system that is
n-dimensional every single real valued a
matrix you could possibly name you can
find its eigenvalues you can look at the
ranks of the null spaces and you can
write through an eigenvector change of
coordinates that system into this Jordan
canonical form this is kind of like the
universal decoder ring for all linear
systems all a and if a single one of
these eigenvalues has positive real part
it's an unstable system if all of these
eigenvalues have negative real part or
zero a real part then it's either
asymptotically stable or neutralized
stable okay really cool stuff you can do
okay that was a lot that was uh but this
is important this is one of the coolest
things in linear systems is kind of
getting to this Jordan form this is
really an important concept so I'm glad
you got to see it all right thank you
[Music]